LELAND: GREAT WORK BY SIMONE AND
MANY OF HER FRIENDS.
WHAT COMES NEXT?
HOW TO GET AMERICA BACK TO WORK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED A NEW
GROUP TO HELP REOPEN THE
COUNTRY.
>> WE’RE ALSO SETTING UP A
COUNCIL, A VERY, VERY GREAT
DOCTORS AND BUSINESS PEOPLE.
I CALL IT THE OPENING OUR
COUNTRY TASK FORCE OR OPENING
OUR COUNTRY COUNCIL.
LELAND: AND JOINING US NOW,
SOMEONE WHO HAS EXPERIENCE WITH
WHITE HOUSE COUNCILS AND TASK
FORCE, SHALL WE SAY.
MACK McCARTY.
IT’S GOOD TO SEE YOU, SIR.
DOES THIS MAKE SENSE TO YOU OR
TOO EARLY?
>> NO, I THINK IT’S ABOUT RIGHT,
LELAND.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT, ALONG
WITH THE GOVERNORS AND MAYORS
AND OTHER LEADERS IN OUR COUNTRY
BOTH IN THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR FIRST NEED TO MEET THE
MOMENT, WHICH WAS THE CRISIS OF
THE PANDEMIC, TO REALLY
SERIOUSLY ADDRESS THE HEALTH
ISSUES.
I THINK THEY--
IF THEY MAKE EVERY EFFORT TO DO
THAT WITH DR. FAUCI AND DR. BIRX
AND OTHERS, TO FLATTEN THE CURVE
SO THE HOSPITALS DO NOT GET
OVERRUN.
ALL OF OUR HEARTS AND ADMIRATION
GO OUT TO THE FIRST RESPONDERS,
AND DOCTORS AND NURSES.
NOW IT’S TIME TO LOOK PAST THE
MOMENT.
NOT TO TAKE OUR EYE OFF THE BALL
TO BE VERY CLEAR.
WE’VE STILL GOT WORK TO DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE SAFE AS MANY
LIVES AS WE CAN FROM THIS VERY
VIRAL EPIDEMIC.
BUT IT’S TIME TO LOOK FORWARD,
HOW WE CAN GET THIS ECONOMY
REOPENED BECAUSE THAT’S ABOUT
RENEWING AND BUILDING LIVES AS
WELL AND HOW TO DO THAT.
SO I THINK THE PRESIDENT’S
TIMING IS ABOUT RIGHT AND OTHER
GOVERNORS ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
TAKING SIMILAR MEASURES IN THEIR
STATES, LELAND.
LELAND: WE HEARD FROM THE
GOVERNOR OF OKLAHOMA WHO TALKED
ABOUT HOW TO EXACTLY REOPEN,
STARTING WITH ELECTIVE
SURGERIES, AND RESTAURANTS AND
ET CETERA.
AS WE LOOK AT THE WEEKLY JOB
NUMBERS.
6.6 MILLION UNEMPLOYMENT GAMES.
6.9 MILLION THE WEEK BEFORE.
3.3 MILLION THE WEEK BEFORE
THAT.
16.78 MILLION, 10% OF THE WORK
FORCE WITHOUT A JOB IN THREE
WEEKS.
DO YOU THINK IT’S FAIR TO SAY
THAT NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER FACED
SOMETHING QUITE LIKE THIS
BEFORE?
>> I THINK THIS SITUATION IS
UNPRECEDENTED, LELAND.
I DON’T THINK THERE’S ANY
QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
IT’S WHIPLASH.
THE ECONOMY WAS MOVING FORWARD
AT A RAPID PACE IN TERMS OF
GROWTH, JOBS AND EVEN WAGE
INCREASES AND ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THE PANDEMIC HIT AND THE ECONOMY
WAS SHUTTERED, SHUTTERED.
AND YOU CAN JUST LOOK AT THE
FRONT PAGES OF NEWSPAPERS, LOOK
AT THOSE UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS,
WHICH RESPECT THE 10%.
SO THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED.
IT’S UNSETTLING AND IT’S
CHALLENGING, BUT I THINK WE CAN
RISE TO MEET THE OCCASION.
LELAND: YOU HAVE A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE IN THIS HAVING
SERVED AT BOTH THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT AND HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL IN BUSINESS BOTH
BEFORE AND AFTER YOUR TIME IN
GOVERNMENT.
WHERE IS THE INTERSECTION THAT
GOVERNMENT CAN ACTUALLY HELP
WHEN IT COMES TO REOPENING THE
COUNTRY AND WHAT DOES GOVERNMENT
NEED TO STAY OUT OF TO ALLOW
AMERICAN BUSINESS AND AMERICAN
PRUNES TO DO AND BE THERE BEST?
>> LELAND, THAT’S THE RIGHT
QUESTION IN MY VIEW.
I THINK THE GOVERNMENT, AGAIN,
BOTH AT THE FEDERAL, STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL HAS TO BE SUPPORTIVE
TO BE ON THE HEALTH FRONT AND
FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL AND PRIVATE
SECTOR FOR THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS.
AND I THINK A PATHWAY AHEAD TO
THE EXTENT IT CAN BE STARTED AND
NOTED.
THAT’S WHAT THE GOVERNMENT CAN
DO, GIVE A FRAMEWORK AND
SUPPORT.
I THINK THE PACKAGE THAT
CONGRESS PASSED FOLLOWING THE
ADMINISTRATION’S LEAD IS A PART
OF THAT.
LELAND: MACK McLARTY OF THE